>>Joe: --again to Android Developer Office
Hours.
I'm Joe Malin, your moderator.
Next to me is Trevor Johns.
>>Trevor: Howdy.
>>Joe: And beside him, down at the end of
the table, um, ignoring us, is Alex Lucas.
Our engineer today is Robert Lee.
>>Trevor: [laughs]
>>Joe: And, uh.
>>Trevor: The world is shifting around Alex.
>>Joe: The world is, the world is moving around
Alex.
It revolves around him.
So with no further ado, let's go to the Moderator
and take our first question for today.
From, uh, Zoliotsko, in Sophia, Bulgaria.
"What's the best approach for an app with
a lot of web—" [chokes] Excuse me.
"Web API calls.
Now I'm using a service + 1 AsyncTask for
all API calls and ugly interfaces to talk
to UI.
Should I use separate AsyncTask for every
API call and how to communicate to the UI
properly?
Thanks."
>>Trevor: Alright.
So, it's a service and a AsyncTask for the
API calls and they wanna know if it's OK to
use separate AsyncTask for every API call.
I think that's probably OK depending on the
nature of your API.
So, the thing to watch out for with AsyncTask
is if your application ends for some reason.
Say you rotate your screen and it relaunches.
The system's going to restart your app.
Those AsyncTasks are never going to complete
as far as your UI are concerned.
And I think they'll still, will they still
run in the background?
I can't remember.
It's iffy.
I wouldn't rely on that behavior.
They may, they may not.
It, so if you're just like, fetching some
information, that's fine.
If you're making something that's a, a destructive
change, right?
You're editing something, you're posting new
data, that's when you need to be a little
bit more careful and make sure that your AsyncTask
actually can run to completion.
Or at the very least to make sure that it's
nothing that's so important that the world
will end if your app does restart.
So you know, if you're making a blog post,
right and the user posts it, you need to make
sure it runs to, it actually appears.
If you make it so that when your app restarts,
you know you check to see if that's posted,
you're probably fine.
Now that said, there are some benefits to
using a service as a background process.
And that is that you can actually, you have
a lot more control over things like fetching
new data.
So the advice we usually give people when
they're using web services inside of their
Android app is to make sure that you're pulling
your data in before the user asks for it.
So when the user's actually in the UI, they
get a nice, fast, responsive experience.
On top of that, users don't always have an
internet connection or it might be a bit flaky.
So if you're on a plane, or commuting to work,
you might be passing through some tunnels.
Or again, a plane's a perfect example.
The user probably still wants people to read
their information, you know, it'll say you're
a feed reader, like the user still wants access
to the RSS Feeds.
If you have a background service you can go
ahead and make sure all this is cached and
available inside of a content provider.
If you're just doing an AsyncTask to go live,
all that's gonna fail.
So I think that's really the big benefit to
use a service.
And for that reason, yeah you probably can
make it work with an AsyncTask but our usual
advice is, not to.
Alex, did you have anything else you wanted
to add on to that?
>>Alex: Well, sure, I'd just really quickly
like to address the part of the question where
he says, "Is one AsyncTask for all calls OK
or should I use you know, what, uh, spin-up
a new AsyncTask per call?"
And I think if you're in a situation where
you have a lot of calls happening.
Like let's say the app you're writing is,
like, the front end for a web service.
Or if you're doing some sort of batch thing.
Like downloading a thousand files from the
internet.
If you don't go the service route, the better
option is really to just create a full blown
background thread.
So AsyncTasks are really designed for, they're
really optimized for very quick tasks.
Like maybe pulling weather information off
the internet.
Or writing something to a file or writing
something to a database.
If you're doing something that's gonna take
a significant amount of time, or if you have
a whole bunch of different tasks that you're
queuing up like that, the best option is really
to have a background thread that just sort
of sleeps and waits for new commands.
And then you can just send those, you know,
send a request for a file or something like
that to the background thread.
The other part of the question I noticed was
about the quote unquote ugly interfaces for
the UI.
There's a facility called a handler that lets
you sort of ship data back and forth.
And like commands back and forth.
Between the UI thread and background threads.
So I would look into using that.
I, without more information of what you're
doing currently I can't really say whether
those are the right, whether your current
approach is the right or wrong way.
But definitely look into handlers.
>>Joe: OK.
Any other comments?
Great.
Thank you very much, gentlemen.
>>Alex: We've got two questions from the Hangout.
>>Joe: OK.
Let's have the first one.
[pause]
Uh, not getting sound.
No.
Are we in the mute?
>>Trevor: Hit the volume up button on the
computer Robert, let's see if we can get some
audio out here.
[volume up clicks]
Oh, we don't.
>>Joe: No.
>>Trevor: Um.
[volume up button clicks]
>>Joe: Hold on just a second.
>>Trevor: Yeah, um, let's go back to Moderator.
>>Joe: OK.
Fine.
>>Trevor: I'm gonna go and step over and debug
the stuff on the soundboard.
>>Joe: OK.
Bear with us.
>>Trevor: yeah.
>>Joe: And we'll come back to you.
>>Trevor: Do you wanna mute my mic here for
a second, Robert?
So that we don't deafen people.
[chuckles]
>>Joe: OK.
We're gonna go back to the moderator for just
a second while we take a look at some technical
issues here.
[someone coughs]
Um, and ask this question from Akhil in Ashburn,
Virginia.
"I'm a beginner to Android application development.
Do you recommend reading the API Guides straight
through?
That's what I've been doing.
The Android training doesn't really feel in
depth."
>>Alex: Right.
Uh.
I guess since Trevor isn't in front of the
camera at the moment I'll be taking this one.
Yeah, reading the API Guides is actually are
really good way to become familiar with Android
development.
I should say that they are, the API Guides
and Android training serve two separate purposes.
The API Guides are more designed for a particular
topic to give you an overview of the API and
all the little features and method calls and
the important elements of it.
The Android training classes are more task
oriented.
In terms of, you know, I wanna sync with a
web service or I wanna efficiently load bitmaps.
Or like, they're very like task based.
Like I wanna accomplish this.
And then a step by step lesson.
Like a series of step by step lessons within
a particular topic.
Of how to go, the uh, the steps that you go
through in order to accomplish that.
And your relevant API calls.
We also provide code snippets and sample code.
Yeah, the API Guides are really good reading.
I would recommend instead of just reading,
which doesn't do a lot for retention of the
topic, especially programming, your best option
is actually—
>>Trevor: Sorry, Alex.
[chuckles]
>>Alex: No worries.
Uh, your best option is actually to have an
idea.
Like a small sample, not necessarily a small
sample project.
But a small exercise.
Like if you're learning how to do networking
code, learn how to pull it in off the internet
or something, and write a small sample app
that does that.
Joe also, we were discussing this beforehand,
and he also brought up the great point that
it's good to have an overarching project in
mind when learning new language.
Or a new platform.
And that will really, that way you can get
a bunch of topics and sort of learn them simultaneously
as you're incorporating these features.
And getting into your project.
>>Joe: Wanna add anything, Trevor?
>>Trevor: I, um, I didn't catch the question
'cause I was busy fixing the sound>>Joe: Oh,
uh, Android beginner to Android application
development.
Do you recommend reading the API guide straight
through?
>>Trevor: OK.
Um.
No, it's really, I think it's mostly a question
of how do you learn, or how do you like your
content delivered.
Um, I know some people like, you know, they
do like reading through the documentation.
And the format we provide is probably a bit
more fast paced than what you'll find in a
longer book that's more geared towards beginners.
Right?
We assume that you have a background in the
Java language.
We assume that you're familiar with most of
the concepts involved in GUI Programming,
and we do rush through things a bit.
Because we assume that the audience has, has
a good, a solid background in this stuff.
And you know, most people, I'd say when they're,
especially if they're getting started, or
if they're coming from a different environment,
might not be familiar with all of that.
And the documentation's all out there, but
you know, you have to go and take a look at
our site.
You might have to look through the Java tutorials
for some of the language stuff.
And with those cases I think you might find
a book to be better.
Uh, we like to, I, I'm a fan of Reto's book,
but there's a lot of good ones out there.
And some people also like video tutorial.
And there's a lot of those out there as well,
too.
So, it's really just a matter of, how do you
like your information delivered.
I do think that the, well, the API guide especially
is probably not the best way to go, but the
Android training and the tutorials and the
developer guide, all great places to start.
I think they do cover everything you need
to know.
But, you know again, it's a different pace.
>>Joe: Um.
Yeah.
I would uh, I'm a technical writer on Android
and so I feel like I understand something
about all of the different stuff we've written
about.
I would say that the API guides were not designed
to be read straight through in order or you
know, you don't need to read all of them in
order to understand how to develop an Android.
I can understand that you might feel that
Android training isn't, doesn't feel like
it's in depth but it'll give you an idea of
some of the tools that you can use to write
Android applications.
As in AsyncTasks and other things like that.
And also the types of problems that you might
run into when you're writing an Android application.
So if you just review them.
And even if you just skim through them you
can get started on a project and then if you
need more help on a particular topic, you
can look at the API guide for that topic.
>>Trevor: Right.
And then, you know, you, um, just to give
you an idea of how I got started with Android.
I read through the first, you know, the first
five pages, I think, under the introduction
material at lifecycles of an application.
What does an activity look like?
How do you do a UI?
All the really basic stuff is clustered right
there at the beginning of the developers guide.
And then from there you can go and read the
individual sections as you come across problems
you'd like to solve.
Yeah.
I do agree with Joe.
Reading the everything on there is a pretty
daunting task.
And it's not structured to really be read
that way.
Um, I mean, you certainly could.
But that's gonna take you quite a while.
>>Joe: Right.
OK.
Since we have somebody in the hangout waiting
to ask a question let's go to him now.
>>Male #1: OK.
Can you hear me now?
>>Trevor: Yes!
Yes we can.
>>Joe: I can, we can year you now.
>>Trevor: And Robert, did you unmute the hangout
computer on the sound board?
Going out live.
There you go.
Now people on YouTube can hear you.
>>Male #1: OK, so I actually have two questions.
The first one's fairly simple.
Um, at Google IO, one of my coworkers asked
about, um, using web APIs to sync shared preferences
and we were told that if we just waited a
few weeks there would be a product released
that would allow us to do that.
Is there any update on what that is?
>>Trevor: I'm not actually sure what that
would be.
>>Male #1: OK, 'cause—
>>Trevor: Um.
Alex, Joe do either of you know what that's
in reference to?
>>Joe: No.
>>Male #1: And the two gentlemen who gave
the talk at Google IO, I'm afraid I don't
remember their names.
But they specifically told us that there was
something coming out specifically to sync
shared preferences using, um, web APIs.
>>Alex: Do you remember the name of the talk,
by any chance?
>>Male #1: Yeah, it is, uh, Building Android
Applications that Use Web APIs.
>>Trevor: [laughs]
>>Alex: OK.
That would make sense.
Yeah.
Uh.
I don't know what topic they're referring
to off the top of my head but I can, we can
track down the guys who gave the talk and
ask—
>>Male #1: Yeah, uh, it's, Yaniv Inbar?
>>Trevor: OK.
Yeah.
I know him.
Yeah, he actually is in charge of a lot of
stuff related to our overall API strategy
at Google.
So.
>>Male #1: OK.
>>Trevor: It doesn't surprise me that we don't
know about it 'cause he is not part of the
Android team.
He's part of the broader API team, again at,
for all of Google.
So, it doesn't surprise me that there's something
going on we haven't heard about it yet.
We'll get some more info from you and we'll
pass it along.
Um, we're gonna go and try and recap all the
questions we can't answer at the beginning
of the show the following week.
So if you can tune in just at the start of
the show next week we'll get that answer for
you.
>>Male #1: OK.
>>Trevor: And if you can post a, actually,
probably this isn't the best question for
StackOverflow since—
>>Joe: Yeah.
>>Trevor: Yeah.
So tune in next week.
We'll get you an answer and have some more
info.
>>Joe: OK.
>>Trevor: And you had another question?
>>Male #1: Yeah.
The second question is involving fragment
transactions with compatibility library.
Um, I have basically a linear layout that
contains multiple fragments.
And what I wanna be able to do is replace
one of them with another fragment.
And because I don't know at the time of replacement
if the number is identical or not.
So I just, I completely erase the row and
refill it with fragments.
The removal process works great.
The problem is, substi—I remove all the
fragments, I commit that change.
And then I try and add new fragments and nothing
happens.
[pause]
>>Alex: Hm.
Do you commit the change with adding the fragments?
>>Male #1: Yes.
Yeah.
It's within one function I iterate through
all the fragments that are stored in that
layout.
Calling remove on each one.
I commit that.
And then on all the fragments that I want
to add to that row, I do an add.
And then commit that after the four loop.
[pause]
>>Alex: I don't know off the top of my head
why that wouldn't work.
>>Male #1: Yeah.
I'm very confused because I don't get any
LogCat messages.
Um, you know, literally nothing other than
that I see the results of the removal but
I don't get the results of the add.
>>Alex: Uh, does it, does it work if you re-add
them in a separate way?
Like if you do the removals and the adds of
the new fragments in the same transaction?
>>Male #1: Uh, no I tried that.
That didn't work.
So I thought maybe I'm having some sort of
an issue with that.
So I put them with two separate transactions.
That doesn't work.
Calling invalidate on the layout doesn't work.
Um, I have this question posted on StackOverflow
but it, I haven't really gotten any hits on
it.
>>Trevor: I think we probably need to see
your code for this.
So—
>>Male #1: [inaudible]
>>Trevor: So if you could take a look at your
StackOverflow question, and post it in the
comment thread on Google + for this live stream
right now, we'll go through after the show,
find your question and take a look through
your code.
Yeah, 'cause it sounds like what you're doing
should work.
It's probably something really subtle.
And so if you post some code we can try and
sort that out for you.
Just make sure.
Usually I don't ask people to do this with
the link, sometimes winds up in the wrong
place.
So again, make sure you find the stream right
now on Google +.
Post a link to your StackOverflow question
there an we'll find that.
>>Male #1: Right.
This is the event page, right?
>>Trevor: Yes.
>>Alex: Yeah.
>>Male #1: OK.
>>Joe: OK?
Sorry we couldn't be more help.
We have somebody else on hangout.
So go ahead.
[pause]
>>Robert: Nobody.
>>Joe: Nobody.
>>Trevor: Silence.
>>Joe: OK.
Silence.
Might have gotten bored and left us.
But we encourage you to come back if you still
have a question.
And we encourage everybody else out there
that if you wanna ask a question, it's perfectly
OK to write in or join the hangout and ask
a question.
I think that we've got a limit of like ten
people on the hangouts.
Which is why we don't encourage everybody
to just jump in, but um, to the ext—
>>Trevor: Jump in if you have a question.
>>Joe: Jump in if you have a question.
Don't just jump in, and we'll answer it.
OK.
Next from Moderator.
"What are your best practices on writing a
web API that'll be interacting with Android.
Are there particular data structures in JSON,
URI construction, or API-side behaviors that'll
make the Android interactions more seamless?"
And that's from Hussain in the Colorado GDG,
Colorado.
>>Trevor: Right.
Um, I can't say there's really anything that
makes working on Android any easier.
I mean, most web APIs have been, the underlying
method of writing them has been designed to
work, um, in a way that works on any language.
Right?
So you have, I'd say most people tend to have
standardized on the restful design pattern.
So, um, basically if you're not familiar with
that, the idea is you have a collection of
nouns which represent whatever object you're
interacting with.
A person record, an event record, whatever
it is.
And then you use the normal http verbs.
Get, put, post, delete, um, patch, things
like that.
To go and make modifications to the data.
When you access those URLs, most people will
either use xml or JSON.
I think either of them is equally easy to
work with.
If you're using xml, just make sure that you're
using a SAX style xml parser rather than something
based on DOM.
Because mobile devices have limited memory.
If you use JSON, I'd say Gson tends to be
one of the better JSON parsers available.
But, you know, JSON's pretty lightweight so
feel free to use whatever works for you in
that case.
Though again, keep an eye out for memory constraints
if you have a very large tree of objects you're
reading in.
it might not make sense to load it all to
memory at the same time.
Again, yeah, just depends on what you're working
with.
Um, other than that, you know, it's really
what works best for your application.
And I don't think, really, one pattern over
another is really gonna make more of a difference
on the Android side.
It's really just a matter of what's easier
to program with.
>>Robert: [inaudible]
>>Trevor: Alright, hey Matthew.
>>Matthew: Yes, um, hello.
>>Joe: Hi.
>>Matthew: Hey, two questions actually.
Uh, one, trying to look into the file system
on Android.
And basically trying to, I downloaded Android
and Google Play can download to my device
using like a DDMS or something to take it
off the device.
It's in the mnt/asec folder.
And it won't let me move the file.
Is that the new app encryption that Google
Play is doing?
>>Trevor: That's correct.
>>Matthew: Rights specific encryption?
>>Trevor: Mm-hm.
Yes.
>>Matthew: [inaudible] the thing off the device?
OK.
>>Trevor: Yeah.
'Cause in the asec, that's all an encrypted
file system and not something that you'll
be able to [inaudible]
>>Matthew: Hmm.
OK.
Does it only work on certain devices?
'Cause I can take it off my phone, which is
an old Gingerbread.
I have no problem accessing that folder whatsoever.
But in Jellybean you can't.
>>Trevor: Yeah, I believe the encryption was
enabled on, I wanna say it was on Jellybean.
And it's only for paid applications.
>>Matthew: Hm.
Mine's free.
[chuckles]
>>Trevor: Hm.
I'm surprised it's encrypted then.
Um.
>>Matthew: So, yeah.
[inaudible]
>>Trevor: At least that was how I understand
it.
I'm not mistaken am I?
>>Joe: Um.
>>Matthew: I heard a rumor about it being
on all applications but [inaudible]
>>Trevor: It might be [inaudible] for the
app.
My info might be a bit out of date.
>>Matthew: [inaudible]
>>Trevor: But it was definitely added in Jellybean.
So.
>>Matthew: Yes.
>>Joe: Right.
>>Matthew: OK.
The other one is, any ideas in how to look
into a JavaLang verify error when running
the app on your, on either an emulator or
on a device.
When you ask Java to verify the class before
it goes to all the decks and everything, it's
perfectly fine.
>>Trevor: Is this, uh, what API level are
you targeting for this?
>>Matthew: I've, this is like two point, I
think it's like two point two.
>>Trevor: Right.
'Cause I want, I know prior to Android two,
you would get a verify error if you used an
API call that was not available on that API
level yet.
On two point two though—
>>Matthew: OK.
I can try that.
>>Trevor: It shouldn't be an issue.
>>Matthew: OK.
I'm running it on a Jellybean device.
>>Trevor: OK.
>>Matthew: Um, and getting that error.
I've tried different emulators and they all
gave me the JavaLang verifier.
But I take you know the APK, decompile it,
take the dex, take it back to the dex to jar,
look at the jar files.
And Java says no problems at all with the
class files.
So.
>>Trevor: Interesting.
>>Matthew: OK.
I'll look at it some more.
Thanks for your [inaudible]
>>Trevor: Yeah, but the only thing I can wonder
is if you're getting a reference to a class
that doesn't exist possibly.
Though I think even that should still work
too.
And like you said, you're on Jellybean.
So.
>>Matthew: Yes.
>>Trevor: It's probably not an issue with
the system APIs in that case.
Possibly something inherent to the way your
application is structured.
>>Matthew: OK.
I'll look into that.
>>Joe: OK.
Thanks.
>>Trevor: OK?
>>Joe: Thank you.
Anybody else?
No?
OK.
Back to Moderator.
Next question is from Julian Brost.
"Is it possible to enhance Google Now as an
app developer?
That is, provide more data or custom cards?"
>>Trevor: Not at this time.
So you can.
To give you a little more information, Google
Now doesn't have an API, so there's no way
to extend it.
But one thing you can do, I don't recommend
people do this.
But it is possible to go and override the,
the Google Now action.
So when you hold down on the home button and
slide up from there, you see the little Google
logo that pulls up Google Now, you can technically
replace that with your own app.
If you wanna provide something that's say,
a replacement for Google Now.
All of Google Now.
Uh, but again, I don't really recommend that.
'cause Google Now is pretty cool and, as a
user I don't think I'd want it replaced on
my phone.
But you know.
That's right now, that's the only option available.
>>Joe: OK.
Thank you.
Next question is from Ramon in Finland.
"I'm planning to use a private key to hash
the payload send to the web API.
I guess it's impossible to keep it 100 percent
secure since it's possible to get the apk
and decompile it.
Anyway, what are the best practices to keep
the key in my Android app safe?"
>>Trevor: OK, that's a little bit tougher.
Because yeah, like you mentioned, it's entirely
possible to decompile an apk.
And if you have your private key stored in
there, somebody looking at the byte code will
be able to find it and remove it.
So, I'd say given that, your best option would
be to obfuscate that key somehow.
So, just probably the easiest way would be
to go and remove the key if they're gonna
try and do it, would be to, just run strings
on your, on your app.
And see what strings are contained in there.
So, probably a good alternative would be to
create some sort of, um, seed for your key.
And use some cryptographic function to go
and convert that into a suitably sized uh,
key.
Hey Robert, could you mute the speakers?
Sorry.
[laughs] That's sort of distracting.
So yeah, basically you know, the, it's the
same idea with a passphrase.
When you log into a Wi-Fi network or something
like that, the passphrase provided is usually
not long enough to actually become a suitable
cryptographic key.
So, there's very [unintelligible] to actually
go and extend that in, some of the [unintelligible]
12 or however many bytes you need for your
actual key material.
Um, a good example of this oh, I'm trying
to remember the name of the algorithm.
I don't think anybody here remembers off the
top of their heads.
Do they?
[pause]
>>Joe: Give us a better hint.
>>Trevor: yeah, will it's an algorithm that
converts a passphrase into a longer key.
[pause]
I think we're probably going to have to look
it up, I think.
>>Joe: Yeah.
>>Trevor: But anyway, um, if you take a look
out there, here are algorithms that basically
will extend a passphrase into something larger.
And that would be a good way to go.
And hide your key.
Alternatively, you know, if you, I guess,
actually you could even use something like
MD5 or SHA1, just to generate a hash of your
key.
And then basically that way when somebody
goes and looks at the strings, they're not
seeing our verbatim key stored in there.
Now I do want to caution there is some advice
out there that I want you not to follow.
And, um, that is, don't use SecureRandom to
generate your key fill material.
So, what I usually see people do in this case
is they'll go and create instances in SecureRandom,
generate, feed their passphrase essentially
in as their random seed.
And then generate however many bytes of random
data.
Assuming that since they're always using the
same seed, they'll always get the same random
data back out.
And the actual answer is that is not guaranteed
to happen.
And I've seen some aps break pretty badly
because of this assumption.
So please, please, please do not use SecureRandom
to generate fill material.
Um, anything else that's deterministic should
be fine.
Alternative, or other things you could do.
You could um, go and concatenate multiple
strings.
You could basically provide, er, apply any
sort of transformation to your original string
so that that way the original key can't be
read out.
I'd say that's the best practice in this case.
MD5, SHA1's probably a good bet.
>>Joe: Yep.
Mm.
Any other comments?
No?
>>Alex: No.
>>Joe: Alright, we'll move on to the next
question.
This is from, um, Mr. HiddenAndroid in Croatia.
"Is there a way to enable full development
access on stock devices?
We now can allow installing debug, apk files,
enable USB debugging in Developer Options
but we can't use really helpful hierarchy
viewer when testing on stock devices."
And a sad face.
>>Trevor: Alright, so I guess there's two
parts to the question here.
The first question is, is it possible to go
and enable full development access?
And to do that you need a custom ROM.
So Android normally has three ways of building.
The normal user build, which you'll find on
pretty much any retail phone you buy.
And then there's also a user debug build,
and an eng build.
Which enable increasing levels of access to
the system.
At the cost of performance and security.
We don't recommend most people use those builds.
Again, there are secure, there are security
implications if you do so.
But if you are making a phone and it's just
for development purposes.
You can go to source.enter.com, check out
the source code there, make your own build.
Assuming the drivers are available for your
device.
Um, not all devices have drivers there.
So you're gonna wanna check and see which
device you have and how well it's supported.
But that said, it sounds like what you really
want is HeirarchyViewer.
And if that's the case there's an even better
solution.
And that is to download something called ViewServer.
ViewServer is the code that is responsible
for export.
That's, that generates the server that HeirarchyViewer
connects to.
It's part of the system but you can also place
it into your app.
And run that same application entirely in
user space.
So, if you go to uh, Roman Guy's GitHub page,
or just search on Google for ViewServer, you'll
find it is the first result I'm sure.
And you can go ahead and just drop those files
right into your application.
I think there's a few changes you make to
your manifest as well.
And what you'll find is, when you try and
connect, as long as that code is part of your
application, ViewServer will work, sorry,
HeirarchyViewer will work just fine.
No special OS build required and that's our
recommended way of getting HeirarchyViewer
to work on a real phone.
Of course you can also run it on an emulator
and it will work just fine there.
Because emulators, I believe, are they user
debug?
>>Joe: Yes.
>>Trevor: I think emulators are user debug
build.
So that's the other alternative
>>Joe: OK.
Great answer.
Thank you very much.
Um, next question is: "This week's Android
Design in Action showed a spinner below a
TextView with horizontally left-aligned text.
Any recommendations on how to implement that?"
And that's from Toby in German.
>>Alex: Yeah.
I'll grab this one.
>>Joe: OK.
>>Alex: Uh, so, I went ahead and looked at
the video that you linked to.
And I think, from my understanding, it isn't
actually TextView hovering over a spinner.
It's just a spinner with one of the rows selected
as its default.
Or as the default value that it's showing.
So that's why, I think the question that our
asker Toby was under the impression that it
was sort of, a TextView hovering with a IRG
order like over the spinner.
And like that's not what that is.
There's just a spinner there.
As far as how the text is left-aligned.
That's easy.
That's just an .xml attribute.
Just set Android gravity to left and it'll
left-align the text.
>>Joe: OK.
Good.
Great answer.
Thank you very much.
A question from Molo in Portland Oregon.
"Can I restrict a startdrag object so that
the dragged object can only be dragged to
a certain area?
I have a listview that I want to drag a row
to another position.
I'd like for the dragged row image to only
drag vertically, not horizontally."
Um.
Any answers from you guys?
'Cause based on my sort of hazy memory of
how this works, I don't think there is.
>>Trevor: Yeah, I can't recall a way to do
this either.
>>Alex: I don't think there's a way.
Even if there is, it's, speaking as a user,
I don't know that I would like that experience
where the thing that I'm dragging is sort
of following my finger but sort of not.
I think it's pretty intuitive that if you're
dragging a listview item around that you can
only drag it to other areas in the list.
So I would leave that as-is.
>>Joe: Mm.
I am, I kind of understand the question because
there's a gesture in like, MAC or windows
where you say, hold down the shift key and
move the cursor or use a cursor arrow.
And that restrains the movement to one access,
rather than moving it all over the screen.
>>Trevor: Right.
>>Joe: But I don't think that's as necessary
on an Android device.
And there's--
>>Alex: Right, that's usually for drawing
a line or something.
>>Joe: Yeah.
>>Alex: Just to draw a moving object.
>>Joe: Right.
>>Alex: To another location.
>>Joe: So I just don't think that the current
API supports that.
OK.
Next , question.
"Web UI."
I'm sorry, from anon.
However that is.
"Web UI guests: Just after the end of the
talk you referred to a new functionality which—"
Oh, we had that question already.
>>Trevor: It was.
That was our live question.
>>Joe: Yes.
OK.
>>Trevor: That said, I think there's actually
one more thing we should probably mention
on this topic.
>>Joe: OK.
>>Trevor: And that is the backup API.
Now, the backup API is a service that's provided
as a part of Android.
Where you can take you know, typically shared
preferences file.
And ask to have it sent to, typically a server
on the cloud.
And that'll get replicated across other devices
when the user restores their data.
Now it's not the same as something that's
actually doing a full sync and merging in
changes across lots of different devices.
That's still a topic we need to follow up
with and even get some more info for you.
But if you're just trying to go and persist
users data somewhere that'll survive you know,
a phone replacement.
Or the user basically just loading in all
their settings, the backup API's a pretty
good option for that.
Now it doesn't always get into the cloud.
It's up to the device manufacturers to decide
where this data is saved.
I've seen some devices will go and save to
the SD card rather than to the cloud.
But I think most devices coming out now do
sync to the cloud.
And again, that's a good option for certain
use cases.
So just keep that in mind.
>>Joe: Great.
Thank you.
>>Alex: Got another question in the Moderator.
>>Joe: Go ahead.
>>Alex: Give me a second.
>>Trevor: You mean in Hangouts.
>>Alex: Yes.
>>Joe: That's Hangout.
>>Alex: Hangouts.
>>Joe: Here we go.
>>Robert: Shoot.
>>Male #2: yeah, later on the list, we utilized
some web APIs in our app that can contain—
>>Joe: Yep.
>>Male #2: Some very large JSON responses.
And this can cause our app to run out of memory.
It might be due to memory pressure from other
things going on the app.
But how do you suggest handling such large
responses?
>>Trevor: Ah.
Excellent question.
So, if you control the API, you could go and
page your responses so that way you only load
up a few pieces of data at a time.
It depends on the nature of your application
that might or might not make sense.
The other, within that, this is sort of what
I mentioned earlier about DOM versus SAX in
the context of xml.
DOM you actually go and load the entire representation
of an xml tree into memory.
Where SAX is a streaming parser.
It will go and read through everything and
generate events.
It will come across certain elements.
But at no point do you have to go and load
the entire tree into memory.
And so, if you're finding that you are encountering
similar problems in JSON.
And JSON really is a lot, you know most JSON
parsers work a lot similarly to how a DOM
based xml parser works.
Just go and you know, I'm not familiar with
any streaming JSON parsers.
There's gotta be one somewhere out there.
I'm just not familiar with the, not sure what
it's called.
But failing that, you could just write your
own that literally just scans through the
xml.
Oh sorry, through the JSON data.
And emits events when it comes across certain
apps.
And you can use that to extract the data you
need.
So you know, say that each element within
your JSON tree has a title, a url, and another
few hundred K worth of data.
Just using an extreme example.
You can just go and extract the url in the
title.
And then when the user clicks on it, you can
go and make a call to that url to fetch the
additional data.
At request.
And that way you can ease up some memory pressure
there.
>>Male #2: Alright.
Do you have any, let's say that that's not
an option.
Are you aware of any good streaming JSON parsers
or any other way to sort of relieve some of
that hurt that's gonna come by streaming all
that content into the app?
>>Trevor: I'll do some research after the
show and I can recommend something assuming
something exists.
I'm sure there is something out there.
Again, not familiar with the name off the
top of my head.
But we'll try and find something for you as
far as a good streaming JSON parser.
But as far as saving memory pressure, that's
always a really difficult issue in Android
apps.
Because you are sharing the device with a
lot of other apps.
And on top of that it's on a mobile device
so memory is limited.
It is definitely different than working on
a desktop or server.
And there's really not much you can do about
that.
Other than to write your application to use
as little memory as possible.
Now there are some [unclear] you can use that
will get you some additional [unclear] space.
But we really don't recommend people use them.
It gives a bad user experience because it
will start evicting other apps from memory
when they shouldn't be.
And on top of that, the amount of memory they
give you is actually not guaranteed.
So it's entirely possible that using these
[unclear] will get you no extra space at all.
It's really just a hint to the OS.
And the OS decides how to handle it.
So really I can't really give you any better
advice other than you're gonna need to be
conservative in your memory usage in general.
>>Alex: If I can ask, what, roughly how big
is the JSON that you're downloading?
Like how much data are you trying to process
at one time?
>>Male #2: Um, it can be several Ks.
I think.
>>Trevor: You should have enough, well, so
it's like 10 kilobytes or less then?
>>Male #2: No.
No, no, no.
We're, I'm sorry, I don't know if it's I don't
have exact rough numbers but I know it can
be um, very large you know paragraphs of text.
On that or other things.
>>Trevor: OK.
Paragraphs, you should be fine.
I mean I'd say as long as you're a few hundred
K or less, no problem.
I'd say even up to a megabyte, I mean that's
the size of a large photo, right?
Or actually, a megabyte would be a small photo.
[laughs] But anyway, I mean, I'd say up to
that size, you're probably still safe.
So if you're running out of memory with paragraphs.
That sort of tells me that there's something
else wrong in your app.
And you just, I'm really curious what in your
app is using all available memory.
But you, I'd expect you'd be running into
other problems just besides your JSON at that
point.
I mean, that's not a lot.
Most devices have gigabytes of memory.
I mean, not many gigabytes.
Maybe a gigabyte.
Maybe half a gigabyte.
But you know, I mean, at that scale, you know,
you're less than a meg. that's a very small
fraction of system memory.
And keep in mind the system will evict other
apps as necessary to make sure your app as
the foreground app has enough memory to run.
So by the time you run out of memory you really
have exhausted everything the device has that
it can give you.
So, I'm, again, I think there's something
else in your app that's causing these problems.
It doesn't sound normal to me.
>>Alex: Have you looked at any sort of memory
monitor?
To look at what structures are being generated
by that, that are taking up memory?
>>Male #2: Yeah, I mean, it's, there's a lot
of um, UI going on.
There's, there's, we've got other resources
being downloaded and integrated into the system,
and it's entirely possible that this is just
a large enough hit into the system that it's
just taking us over the top.
But we don't experience this, this 'out of
memory' in any other area except when we're
loading up this JSON.
>>Trevor: Hm.
>>Alex: interesting
>>Trevor: Yeah, that is an interesting problem.
[pause]
>>Male #2: So if you do have, if you are able
to find a streaming JSON parser, that would
be awesome.
>>Trevor: Yeah, well we'll see what we can
find for you.
Um, I think that's probably the best approach
here.
Given that, I mean like, it's entirely possible
to that I'm just guessing maybe you occasionally
run across a really, an abnormally large block
of JSON data.
I mean, the problem you're having is very
similar to loading bitmaps from the internet.
And bitmaps are fairly large.
The advice we usually give is, there's enough
space to load twice your screen size in the
Java heap.
And you know, any reasonably sized block of
JSON data is going to be less than that.
So yeah, you probably are just right at the
edge there.
But we'll see what we can find that can help
with this.
[key strokes in background]
>>Alex: What parser are you using right now?
>>Joe: Yeah, I was gonna ask that.
>>Alex: [inaudible]
>>Male #2: We're using Jackson.
We thought it should be the fastest.
>>Trevor: Sorry?
>>Male #2: Jackson.
>>Trevor: OK.
>>Alex: OK.
>>Joe: OK.
Any other comments?
>>Trevor: Ah, just make a note here.
>>Joe: OK.
>>Trevor: We, yeah, so, as far as advice,
like I said earlier, we'll dedicate a few
minutes of the next show to go over any questions
we couldn't answer.
So we'll have an answer for you then.
So, it'll be two pm next Wednesday.
Be sure to tune in.
Yeah, alternatively you can also leave a comment
on the event page and we'll follow up on the
event page too, so that way we can get you
an answer quicker.
>>Joe: Thank you.
Um, yes?
Anybody else there?
OK.
So, we'll move on to the next question in
Moderator.
Which is from Kristo in Tallinn—excuse me.
Estonia.
"I think that Android is very close to being
feature complete.
But why does it seem like not enough effort
is put on HTML5 support, which is still very
laggy on mobile even on quad-core.
And why are there still no user accounts?
Especially guest."
[pause]
>>Trevor: That's, I'm not sure we can actually
really answer too much about that.
'cause that's really going into the road map,
as far as, you know for Android.
Which Is something we generally can't talk
about.
At least not publicly.
Now, as far as HTML5 support, I'd say a lot
of the effort lately has gone into Chrome.
And as a result, the built-in web view client
is a little bit lacking in features.
That's sort of a complicated issue because
not all of Chrome is open source.
It is something the teams are working on.
But I can' tell you how they're going to address
that.
Again that's a forward looking statement that
I, you know, we can't talk about on the air.
But these are all good points and we definitely
listen to the feedback in the community in
deciding how we spend our engineering time.
So I'll just take this question as a feature
request.
And make sure that that gets passed along.
>>Joe: OK.
[sound cuts out]
So the question is, is there a way--?
Is there a way of adjusting the padding on
the, um, label for the spinner.
>>Alex: It's on the text within the spinner.
I guess he wants to left-align that within
the spinner.
>>Joe: I see.
OK.
So, the question is, how do I left-align text
within the spinner itself?
>>Alex: Right.
OK.
Uh, I don't know the answer to that off the
top of my head.
Is Roman lurking in the Hangout by any chance?
>>Trevor: [laughs]
>>Alex: Because he always knows the answer
to this, the layout question.
No, Roman?
Was hoping if we said his name a couple times
it would sort of summon him.
We'll have to, we'll have to look into that.
>>Joe: Right.
>>Alex: And have an answer for you next week.
Also, if you could, link, if you want to,
ask the question in StackOverlow.
And then link to that site with a question
within Moderator.
We can get an answer there.
It's a handy place for us to address sample
code.
>>Trevor: Moderator I think is, the Moderator
section for this week might be locked by the
time they do that.
So if you can't post to Moderator, again go
to our event page Google +.
Make a comment there and we'll follow up with
you that way, too.
>>Alex: Yeah.
>>Joe: OK.
Great.
Thanks.
Um.
Next question from Moderator.
"What would you recommend if your Android
app needs to interact with a SOAP web service?"
This is from Bellinghammer.
>>Trevor: So fun.
[laughs] Use REST.
What are you thinking?
SOAP?
>>Alex: Well, you don't always have control
over—
>>Trevor: I know, you don't.
>>Joe: I think that was said in jest.
>>Trevor: It was.
It was.
I'm just not a fan of SOAP myself.
>>Alex: Right.
>>Trevor: But, yeah, that'--, I'm not sure,
familiar with any really good SOAP libraries
in Android.
Does anybody else know one?
>>Alex: I don't know off the top of my head.
Though I think the, the point of SOAP is sort
of, you don't need a SOAP library so much
as you need something to generate the code
interact with that web service for you.
>>Trevor: Right.
>>Alex: That's, the point is SOAP, is you
don't have to understand SOAP.
Which, [laughs] is kind of odd.
It's kind of a little weird approach.
We all of us prefer REST.
But if you can find a Java utility that will
not necessarily Android specific, but it the
kind of one that will generate Java interface
files and it can modify those to use the web
clients available in Android.
>> Trevor: I usually recommend against doing
that though because a lot of the web services
libraries that you'll find for Java, in particular,
are designed for desktop environments.
And they're really not conservative when it
comes to memory use.
You run into problems with them.
So I'd actually go out of your way to find
one that's specifically designed for Android.
>>Alex: Right.
>>Trevor: With that in mind, I just did a
quick search here.
There's one here at the top of my search results
called KSOAP to Android.
I don't have any experience with it.
But it does say it's a lightweight and efficient
SOAP client library for Android.
So, that might be a good place to start.
[pause]
>>Alex: I didn't know there actually was one
for Android.
That's cool.
>>Joe: Yeah, doesn't surprise me.
I think there's cool stuff out there—
>>Trevor: There's enough SOAP web services
out there that you know, like you said, you
can't control what web service you're interacting
with if you didn't write it.
So it's good that these client libraries are
out there.
If you are writing new APIs please use REST.
It makes me happy.
But other than that, I mean, SOAP itself,
as an end user, there definitely are some
benefits of using it.
And yeah, I just, just so you know, I did
a search for SOAP Android on Google.
There's also one right under it called Android
SOAP enabler.
Again, we don't have any experience with either
of these APIs. so feel free to give them a
try.
Let us know what you think, actually, so we
can give feedback to other people who are
asking similar questions.
But, we can't endorse either of them.
>>Joe: OK.
We're getting towards the end of the hour
here so let's move forward pretty quickly.
Here's another question from Bellinghammer.
"After doing some profiling, it appears that
most of the time spent in some https-based
web service requests is downloading and validating
the server certificate.
Is there a way to cache the certificate for
subsequent requests?"
>>Trevor: I'm not sure you want to.
Um, that certificate validation is, needs
to be done on a per request basis.
To make sure that nobody has tampered with
you with the response coming back from the
server.
I mean, this is of, course, assuming you're
using https.
If you're using http, none of this applies.
But if you are using a secure connection , there's
probably a reason you're doing that.
And every request needs to be validated.
To make sure that say, somebody hasn't gone
and swapped out your certificate using a man-in-the-middle
attack.
Uh, yeah.
These thing are rare.
But there are reasons the, you know, there
are reasons why SSL and TLS exists.
There are attacks that do this sort of thing.
And you need to check for it.
Unfortunately there's really not a good work
around there.
Now some of the work done on Speedy is specifically
trying to go and speed up SSL and TLS.
And so you could use it.
I imagine there's probably a Speedy library
out there for Android.
I'm, I think so anyway.
Yeah.
I actually, yeah.
Chrome probably uses it.
I'm sure there's a way to go and get that
working.
But most servers out there I think don't support
Speedy yet.
But that, this is precisely the sort of problem
that engineers are working on right now, to
go and try to speed up SSL.
So it's a valid question.
Unfortunately it's not an easy answer.
>>Alex: Got a hangout question.
>>Joe: Go ahead.
[pause]
>>Male #3: Asking about a REST question.
>>Trevor: I’m sorry.
We missed the beginning there.
>>Joe: Yeah.
You've got a REST question?
>>Male #3: Yes.
Correct.
Obviously, consuming REST services is pretty
cool.
So the question is, is there a better way
to consume a REST service besides only using
raw attaching http drive, or the UL connection?
Is there any library you would recommend which
helps in, you know, mapping resources, to
URLs and this kind of stuff?
>>Trevor: SO, I used to work on the Gdata
team.
And you know, like I said, I worked with UDEV
background.
I was on that team.
Working on, I was on a lot of the APIs her
at Google.
And we spent a lot of time writing client
libraries that were very, very tightly focused
on different APIs. and it did make things
a lot easier to work with.
But on the other hand it's a lot of effort
to maintain those.
And it actually, in a lot of cases, had a
lot of complexity, I found.
And as a result I think pretty much everyone
on the API team actually usually preferred
just to use cURL whenever they were testing
something.
Rather than going through all the, effort
of trying to set up a client library.
>>Male #3: OK.
>>Trevor: Now that said, that's not to say
that you couldn't write a very nice clean
client library that's very targeted to a very
specific use case and get really nice results.
But, I think that the beauty of REST is it's
destined to be very easy to use without a
client library.
So I think there is, um, there's a case in
writing client libraries in a service by service
basis.
So say you wanna talk to, just pulling an
example off the top of my head, say you wanna
talk to Google cloud messaging.
Right?
It would make sense to write a Google cloud
messaging library that knows all the intricacies
of that service, and then, marshals your ht
requests for you and makes everything very
clean.
you never have to know the raw protocol.
I think that's a valid effort.
But I think trying to make a very generic
REST client library, you wind up writing something
that looks exactly like an http client library.
But more likely than not, adding a lot of
complexity on top of it.
So I'm not convinced there's a lot of benefit
there.
If you do happen to know an really good client
libraries for doing this, let me know.
I'd love to take a look at them, 'cause it
is something I've worked on in the past.
But nothing, I've never found anything I really
liked to try to do it.
>>Male #3: I actually have had some experience
with cREST.
It's a very small library.
And it mimics the way jacksRS or jersey works.
With imitations.
And that was pretty cool.
But it's very small and only maintained by
one person.
>>Trevor: [laughs]
>>Male #3: So it's not something to rely on
on a daily basis.
But the approach was pretty cool.
Because you only had those imitations because
everything happens between us.
And I think there's basically room for such
a library but I just don't know any which
is suitable.
>>Joe: Well, you can get to work on it.
>>Trevor: [laughs] Yeah.
I'm definitely [inaudible]
>>Joe: The Google attitude is, if you see
something broken, you fix it.
But, I would Google it too and see if there's
somebody out there doing this.
I mean, if there is space for it, maybe somebody
has done it.. but I tend to agree with Trevor
that by the time you come up with something
that's general purpose enough to address all
the different sorts of things you're dealing
with a lot of complexity.
In trying to map specific things into a generalized
client library.
>>Alex: and are you trying to uh, communicate
with your own web service?
Or some other third party web service?
>>Male #3: That's a third party.
Or just any web service basically.
>>Alex: OK.
The solution that I've used in the past, I
wrote an app once that communicated with like
ten or 11 different web services.
And the strategy I implemented was I would
bug them and ask them to write a client library
in my language of choice
>>Trevor: [laughs]
>>Alex: And I would make a case where I was,
it was written in C Sharp actually.
But we made a case for it.
There's all these C Sharp developers who wanna
build awesome things for you.
But you know, they can't unless you just like
give us a client library, we'll build awesome
things.
>>Male #3: Mm.
Yeah.
>>Alex: and a lot of the times they would.
So I would definitely don't be afraid to just
bug people and say "Build me an Android client."
>>Male #3: [laughs] OK.
That's funny.
I'll try.
[laughter]
>>Joe: Thanks for your question.
It's a good question.
>>Male #3: Thanks.
Goodbye.
>>Joe: Anybody else out there?
OK.
Then we, as far as I can tell, we only have
one question left.
So and I think we answered this already but
this is from Minsko in Milford, Ohio.
"Where do apps get installed on Android?
I see a mnt/asec on my Nexus7.
Is that where Google Play puts the apps with
device specific encryption?"
>>Trevor: To which the answer is "Yes."
>>Joe: Yeah.
Yes.
Yeah.
OK so I think we've covered that.
Anybody else out there?
Now's your chance to jump into the Hangout
and get your question answered immediately.
Yes?
No?
>>Male #4: Yes.
I have a question.
>>Trevor: Ah.
So we have somebody.
>>Joe: Shoot.
[pause]
>>Joe: Hello?
>>Male #4: Yeah, uh Hello?
>>Joe: Yeah.
>>Trevor: Yes.
>>Male #4: Yeah, I tried to [inaudible] web
service was that I was the, uh, webserver.
And I wonder if you look at all works with
[inaudible].
>>Trevor: Sorry I didn't quite catch that.
Something about a web server?
>>Male #4: Uh, web server.
>>Joe: Yes.
So can you repeat the question please?
>>Male #4: And I wonder if, is, I wonder if,
[inaudible] works with specific [inaudible]
>>Joe: hm.
>>Male #4: I tried to develop a web service.
>>Trevor: yeah, did you catch what he said?
>>Joe: Yeah, I'm still not getting it.
Is it possible that you could type in the
question for us?
>>Male #4: Yeah.
[pause]
>>Joe: and bear with us for just a second.
>>Joe: He's typing.
OK.
Good.
>>Trevor: It's OK.
We have a couple minutes left.
>>Joe: Yeah.
>>Trevor: We have really a couple minutes.
[pause]
This is where we need some theme music.
>>Joe: Right.
>>Trevor: Like you know, the Jeopardy theme.
>>Joe: The Jeopardy theme would be good.
Or—
>>Alex: I think the jeopardy theme has been
played too many—
>>Joe: It's been done, yeah.
Too many—
>>Alex: I like the Katamari Damacy theme [inaudible]
>>Joe: [laughs]
>>Trevor: Yeah, that would be epic.
>>Alex: Unfortunately if we'd played it over
YouTube we'd have to mute the entire video.
>>Joe: Yeah.
>>Trevor: Yeah.
>>Joe: that's the problem with a lot of those—
>>Alex: [inaudible]
>>Trevor: Licensing piece.
>>Alex: Yeah.
>>Joe: We have to find something that's freeware.
>>Alex: We need some creative commons waiting
music.
>>Trevor: Yeah, like the music we use at the
top of the show.
>>Alex: Yes.
>>Joe: Yes.
>>Alex: Or we could accept sponsors.
>>Joe: Right.
>>Alex: if a band wants to create some play
music for us.
>>Joe: Did we get something here?
>>Alex: Alright we have the question now.
>>Trevor: OK.
Cool.
>>Alex: I try to develop a web service whose
data is on a web server.
And I wonder if local host runs with http
client?
>>Trevor: OK.
OK.
So you're, so it's a, you're basically trying
to develop a web, a, a web app that's running
on the Android device, and then accessing
a local server running on the Android device,
is that correct?
>>Male #4: Yeah.
>>Trevor: OK.
OK that makes sense.
So yeah, I think that's actually possible.
You do have to request a permission to indicate
that you want to run a server.
I believe.
And then you just go ahead and open up a local
port.
There's a lot of other cases where that's
actually useful.
For example for the longest time that used
to be a recommendation to people trying to
do something really complicated with streaming
video.
And you know, DRM and things like that.
As you know, writing your own local server
to go and buffer to the video stream to the
local media playback system.
But, I mean, in your case I think that's entirely
possible.
That being said, it is a bit heavy weight.
You have to go and run your web server.
You're gonna have to run whatever backend
language you're using.
And that's on top of whatever's going to be
rendered in the web view.
So I usually don't recommend that people take
that approach.
If you're really going to do this, I recommend
writing everything in JavaScript if possible.
That's gonna be a lot friendlier, both in
terms of CPU and memory usage.
And you can do pretty much, since you're all
interacting locally anyway, there's really
no reason why you couldn't do everything you're
doing in php inside of JavaScript, and again,
like I said, a lot of these languages like
php are designed to be run on a server where
you have gigabytes and gigabytes and gigabytes
of memory available at your disposal.
And on a mobile device you really don't.
you're, you might have you know, a gig total
to everything on the system.
And as an application developer you're limited
to you know, hundreds of megabytes if not
tens of megabytes.
So php really, the problem there is going
to be getting php to fit into memory.
>>Joe :Right.
That's a good point.
It strikes me though that, I'm sure that somebody
must have tried to tackle this before.
So I'm wondering if looking through StackOverflow
or even Google itself would come up maybe
with some solutions for doing at sort of server
running on a device.
>>Trevor: I'm sure people have tried.
But again, the problem is, it's not, it's
not a good architecture is what I'm saying.
>>Joe: Right.
I'm not saying—
>>Trevor: You're wasting CPU and memory.
[laughs]
>>Joe: I'm not saying that running LAMP, the
LAMP stack on an Android device.
But running something that is tuned specifically
for Android that accomplishes the same net
effect.
Somebody may have come out with a light weight
solution.
Because I agree with you, trying to run the
LAMP stack in Android is gonna be a real challenge.
>>Trevor: yeah.
I think the lightest weight solution though
is just to go and load your html file from
disk.
And then again, doing everything probably
in JavaScript is going to be your easiest
option.
And plus, JavaScript is sort of a cool language.
Or get to deal with prototypes and all that
fun stuff.
Definitely pretty different than php but,
it's a fun language to learn.
>>Joe: Now, OK.
Thank you.
>>Trevor: Alright, I think we're out of time.
So.
>>Joe: We've run over.
Sorry about that.
But it was a good question at the end.
>>Trevor: It was a very good question.
I actually liked it.
>>Joe: Thank you very much for joining us
and we will see you again next week.
Anything to add?
>>Trevor: I believe next week's topic is going
to be on censors.
Don't quote me on that.
I think it's still tentative.
Most likely we're gonna have somebody on here
who can talk about censors.
But stay tuned to our Google + page.
We'll make a formal announcement.
Let you know what the topic is for sure.
As always we broadcast Wednesdays two pm pacific
time.
Feel free to ask us questions in Moderator
before the show.
Or join us live and ask us questions via hangout.
Alright.
>>Joe: Great.
Thank you very much for joining us.
>>Trevor: See you everyone!